تتكرر الصفحات المضجع في ايران اليوم
افاقت ايران على سرقات جديده لامهات الجدد
اثر انتشار خبر اعدام شابين في اوائل
العشرينات من العمر محمد كرامي ومحمد حسين
مما يرفع عدد المحتاجين الذين اعدمتهم
السلطاته الى اربعه منذ بدء الحركه
الاحتجاجيه في سبتمبر جميع الذين
اعدمواجهم محاكمات سريعه خلف الابواب
المغلقه في محاكمات لا تشبه اي اجراءات
قضائيه ذات مغزى هذا ما تؤكده منظمه العفو
الدوليه وهو ما طبقته محاكم النظام بحق
الشابين فقرار الاعدام الصدر في محاكمه
سريعه رفقها حرمانهما من اختيار من يدافع
عنهما وقف فرنسي
في الارض وهي تهمه عقوبتها الاعدام منذ
ثوره الخميني قبل عقود وحتى الان هناك
10 محكوما بالاعدام وتنتظرهم المشانق على
خلفيه اتهامات المرتبطه بالاحتجاجات ورغم
الاذنات الدوليه لعمليات الاعدام والقمع
المتواصل بحق المحتاجين الا ان السلطات
الايرانيه تواصل القمع باشكاله المختلفه
اذ قتل عناصر النظام 500 2017 محتجا على
الاقل واعتقلت اجهزته اكثر من
19,200 وفقا لمنظمات حقوقيه في ايران حنان
المصري العربي